when we're told you have to be
vulnerable right it's it's scary to a
lot of people it doesn't mean you have
to walk through the holes crying every
day that's not what it means
um what vulnerability means simply as I
said before I made a mistake I don't
understand I don't know I need help
because that is a position of weakness
right because as Leaders we think we
have to know all the answers we think we
have to have we have to be right all the
time and the problem is is when we
project that
it actually has a negative impact which
is we now put pressure in people that
they always have to be right and they
have to avoid the answers because I'm
always right and I have all the answers
in other words you'll never get the
truth out of anybody
because that's the example that you set
being vulnerable when you say in a
meeting I you know I don't know or I
don't understand can somebody explain
that to me again what you're doing is
you're creating an environment where
other people can say I don't know can
you explain it to me and you get more
information that way